رحله بحث يخوضها مالك تويتر ايلون ماسك عن
رئيس تنفيذي سي اوه جديد لمنصته الزرقاء
في اشاره الى اقتراب مغادرته اداره
العصفور الازرق فبعد استطلاع طرحه ماسك
على المنصه الزرقاء والذي صوت من خلاله
57.5 لصالح تنحيه عن منصبه كرئيس تنفيذيه
للشركه تتزايد تساؤلات عن شخصيه المدير
الجديد لمنصه تويتر
اكدت ان ابرز المرشحين محتمالين لمنصب
رئيس تنفيذ جديد او سي او في تويتر هم
معاونين ماسك الذين كانوا يساعدونه في
اداره الشركه منذ تواليه من الصبح ابرزهم
جيسون
وديفيد سعد وسرير عامه كريشنال
لكن بعض وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه قالت بان
المدير المقبل منصه تويتر قد يكون جاره
كوشنر صهر الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب فبعد الاستطلاع الذي اجراه ماسك قام
رجل الاعمال جيسون كلاك كلاكنيس بنشر
استطلاع خاص به يسال المتابعين عما اذا
كان يجب عليه
اداره الشركه بشكل منفصل او معا او ما اذا
كان يجب على شخص اخر توالي المسؤوليه اما
ديفيد سكس فلم يقدم اي موقف خصوصا وانه
يعتبر من بين الفريق المؤسس الاصلي وهو
بايبال يتمتع بخبره في اداره شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي
ووافقه شبكه سينان
كريشنا قد يكون هو الخيار الابراج
للمجموعه خصوصا وانا لديه خبره مباشره في
العمل بتويتر
وعمل سابقا على منتجات اعلانيه في فيسبوك
وسناب شات
[موسيقى]